Lee is with us in South Carolina highly
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show very
guys good afternoon my question is what
should we be investing right now in this
downturn well I mean that the stock
market is down for one thing obviously
and so continuing to fund your 401k with
good mutual funds is what I'm doing and
I'm in the middle of building a building
over here next door for the next piece
of growth for Remzi solutions so I don't
have a bunch of spare cash to throw into
mutual funds while the mother on sale
right now or I would have but I am
continuing my steady 401k Rachel and
Winston you know they're doing their
401k so that's down other things you can
look around it you know if there are
things that you are normally purchasing
that are down real estate is not down
right now interest rates are down on
mortgages and so refinancing is a good
time right now but as far as straight-up
investing the biggest thing it's on sale
right now is the stock market yeah and
I've heard a lot of people you know
because everything is quote-unquote on
sale they're trying to get in there and
like do different things and all of that
but we're still pretty boring even in a
downturn with the market of just doing
mutual funds I mean so Allah knows
they're a single stock is there
something I should kind of dip in and go
around we're pretty simple I'm just like
hey it's mutual funds so you're still
gonna get a great deal on that but at
the end of the day being able to
diversify your risk and not going after
these single stocks but I've seen a lot
of people in talks of that they're
trying to like pin the system do all
these like kind of different things
because it's down but don't take the
common you know I mean use the common
sense approach of mutual funds all the
way diversify that risk you know that's
a good point because what happens is
people lose money I in stuff like
investing in mutual funds or investing
in stock market in in general they lose
money when they're fearful and they pull
at the wrong time
they also can lose money when the greedy
and they're saying you know
I'm gonna jump in yes no and it's like
that kind of a thing and you're not
doing that Austin that's not your thing
I mean Lee I'm sorry that's not what
you're suggesting you're just asking
knowledge questions yeah the timing is
good what can we do
well good mutual funds but what you're
suggesting right choice I'm gonna try
something super risky right now because
I'm so excited that everything's on sale
that's the kind of agreed right so
that's more than just wise steady
investing and so be aware of that that
greedy thing there is a famous Warren
Buffett saying and he doesn't mean
greedy like a lack of virtue type greedy
but he always says being greedy greedy
when others are fearful and fearful when
others are greedy and he doesn't mean be
fearful sucking their thumb in the
corner or him being greedy like I'm
something from a movie but his point is
be investing when people are not
investing and when they're not investing
maybe you know or when they are
investing maybe you shouldn't be that
kind of thing he's always once he's a
contrarian yeah the opposite of what's
going on but just beware that if you get
desperate you get stupid and if you're
greedy you get stupid so Rachael's point
is don't dive off into some weird thing
or some single stock or some you can get
scammed with this kind of stuff going on
right now that you know the
opportunities to jump in right now and
it's the coronaviruses
high suit this is awesome you know and
know that that right there is a good you
start feeling that kind of been emotion
that's not what he's saying but your
warning against that so yeah I think
just continuing to do your 401k
investing and if you have some extra
money you will leave alone ten years
yeah it's a great time the March stock
markets on sale when I was a kid there
used to have blue lights at Kmart when
there's a sale and you'd run over to
where the blue light was and buy
whatever it was on sale and so that's
what's happening on the stock market
right now there's a blue light on
[Music]